wer sich nicht impfen lässt soll ja
selber für tests in zukunft bezahlen
also ich habe mich dahingehend geäussert
dazu stehe ich auch dass es langfristig
müssen wir das überlegen aber ist also
langfristig na ja also wir haben jetzt
bald jedem ein impf angebot gemacht aber
ich finde es wichtig weil wir ja wissen
dass zum beispiel auch wenn ich doppelt
geimpft bin kann ich mich trotzdem noch
infizieren und kann das virus auch
weiter geben also ich weiß von vielen ja
auch doppelt geimpft sind die sich gerne
testen lassen würden
also ich würde das an der anzahl
festmachen dass ich sage ich habe noch
für eine gewisse zeit habe ich bis jetzt
heißt bis zur bundestagswahl und das hat
mit der bundestagswahl nichts natürlich
fragt ja das hat etwas damit zu tun wie
wir weiter im hdmi geschehen voran komme
weil wir wissen ja dass wir immer mehr
leute auch impfen und deswegen komme ich
ja auch darauf dass wir eine andere
strategie fahren wir sagen worden
ich weiß ja nicht wie sich jetzt das
virus entwickelt deswegen sage ich dem
blue mit low mensch ich möchte nicht
dass mit steuergeldern dann ist auch
jetzt ganz vorsichtig ja das ist welche
neuer geldern derjenige der sich impfen
lassen könnte also keine medizinischen
gründe hat sich täglich auf kosten der
allgemeinheit impfen lässt damit der
abends ins restaurant kann das möchte
ich nicht aber ich muss sagen ein
gewisses kontingent weil die menschen
haben ein interesse daran auch wenn sie
vollständig geimpft sind also ich könnte
mir vorstellen
ein test wird weiter bezahlt pro woche
dass das wäre für mich in ordnung warum
um auch das wissen nicht nur derjenigen
die nicht geimpft sind sondern auch
diejenigen geimpft sind diese sicherheit
zu geben ich bin kein virus träger ich
gebe das ist der der ich bleibe jetzt
mal in ihrer logik der der nicht geimpft
ist darf nach ihrer logik da nur ein
mann das restaurant nein alle alle nein
ich sage ja der negativ getan in einer
gewissen in einem gewissen zeitraum ja
wenn wir noch mehr weitergekommen sind
und wenn wirklich jeder ein angebot
bekommen hat dass das aber jetzt wird es
jetzt echt wischiwaschi über seine worte
nicht so wir haben nicht nein die haben
doch neben argumentiert und sagten sehr
vehement weil sie sozusagen als
vertreterin der der fdp natürlich die
monstranz der freiheit vor sich her
tragen sagt es künftig sein
ein entschuldigung das ist keine
monstranz es geht damit als katholikin
und transfers sei sehr positiv
es geht darum dass ich sage wenn jemand
nicht geimpft ist ja aber negativ
getestet hat er die gleichen
freiheitsrechte das muss sich unabhängig
von der wenn sie sagen es gibt nicht
menschen sozusagen erster und zweiter
klasse
ja genau das gilt für mich die haben das
ja immer die 3g s geimpft getesteten
gewesen so den haben wir immer die
gleichen freiheitsrechte gegeben und
diese nicht bezahlen da steigen sie aus
fdp aus nein gar nicht steige ich aus
dass der markt wie machen wir das
das hat den markt wenn sie das ernst
nehmen wenn sie sagen wenn sie sagen mir
sind die leute die sich nicht impfen
lassen und genau so wichtig wie die
anderen und ich lebe dieses anliegen ist
es geht hat entschuldigungen das ernst
ganz kurz dann muss das doch auf allen
ebenen gelten da müssen wir auch im
zeitplan gesellschaft auch bereits an
den preis dafür zu bezahlen
ich nehme es ernst dass ich sage ich
kann nicht einen die impften ein nicht
geimpften der negativ getestet es dem
kann ich nicht seine grundrechte
wegnimmt darauf kommt es mir also
bezahlt muss er trotzdem selber ja sie
bestrafen da für mich bestrafen ihn gar
nicht dafür ich sage du kannst ein test
möglicherweise frei haben aber ich kann
nicht die gesellschaft dafür bezahlen
lassen dass obwohl du dich impfen lassen
könntest du jetzt täglich jeden abend
party feiert ich finde das ist ein
unterschied zu den grundrechten er hat
die möglichkeit und das ist das
entscheidende
wir wollen keine impfpflicht und ich
habe immer argumentiert und die breite
politik hat immer argumentiert ich habe
immer die möglichkeit wenn ich die
entscheidung getroffen habe mich nicht
impfen zu lassen mich aber am leben
durch einen frei test heraus zu testen
und das muss ich mich selber zahlen das
möchte wenn ich in der lage bin dazu das
zu tun wenn ich in der lage bin zu
bezahlen wir haben gerade herrn söder
gehört das ist tolle akustik geld ja
aber herr söder möchte ja so hat nicht
verstanden
spezielle rechte nur für geimpfte haben
geimpfte und genesen jemand der wenig
geld zu verfügung hatten
kann ich meine kneipe was heißt das doch
der kann ja einmal in die kneipe gehen
beim an der woche naja das ist jetzt ein
vorschlag das ist wissen konkret
ist ja auch so dass wir ein in der woche
pro woche ein frei test haben ist ja im
moment genauso moment im moment frau war
helfen sie mir im moment leistet sich
jeder wenn es sein muss auch zweimal am
tag oder auch mehrfach wie viele hagener
wir haben es eine gewisse zeit dass man
einen hat das ist doch so im moment im
moment testet jeder der sich möchte wenn
es sein muss auch dreimal am tag damit
selbst heißt ja klar aber das team muss
ich mich ich habe die selbsttests und
ich habe die tests die ich durch die
schleuse unterstation genau dann kann
doch jeder jeden tag hin gewinner das
möchte ja also ich habe als ich noch
nicht doppelt geimpft bei unterschreiben
müssen denken dass nur einmal die woche
mache okay ist ja auch ländersache
also pcr test muss man zum beispiel
bezieht von antigene von antigenen genau
zum und das registergericht man auch
natürlich wenn man irgend eine party
feiern was anderes ja und es gibt
bundesländer in dem man sich zweimal in
der woche testen das immer wann auch in
den schulen bittet der diskutierten nur
zweimal oder doch dreimal
aber die eigentliche debatte die sich ja
dahinter verbirgt ist in meiner
perspektive andere nämlich die zwischen
den anliegen des gemeinschafts schutzes
der beim impfen oft unter den tisch
fällt
also ich impfe mich nicht nur damit ich
möglichst keinen schweren verlauf kriege
falls sich infiziert bin sondern ich im
für mich auch weil es dazu hilft das
virus zurückzudrängen und deswegen
profitieren die ungeimpften immer auch
von den geimpften auf der anderen seite
gehört zum gemeinschafts schutz auch
dass diejenigen die sich nicht impfen
lassen können das ist durchaus eine ganz
schön große gruppe jugendliche kinder
oder diejenigen die im skeptisch bleiben
oder das im vertrauen noch nicht so
entwickeln konnten trotzdem an dieser
gemeinschaft teilhaben können und
gleichzeitig würde ich immer fragen was
ist eigentlich die funktion dieser rede
wieso reden wir jetzt seit einer woche
darüber
wir reden natürlich in darüber weil alle
plötzlich merken es gibt eine
impfmüdigkeit das gegen skepsis und die
proteste in frankreich beispielsweise
große gesellschaftliche
auseinandersetzung die auch zeigen dass
das mittel des zwangs untersagt sohn
möglicherweise nicht das richtige ist
wenn man
noch viel überzeugungsarbeit vor sich
hat nehmen sie die 20 bis 30 jährigen
die in ihren generation
monatelang hat man in zweierlei gesagt
erstens du bist jung du hast nicht zur
risikogruppe und 20 impfen kannst erst
mal vergessen
plötzlich ist von der impfstoff
knappheit wir sind wir in einen
überschuss geraten und plötzlich sollen
diese 20 jährigen sofort verstehen dass
sie in die impf straße an die
universität gehören
und dazwischen liegt mir zu wenig werben
der kommunikation und es wird auch ein
bisschen unterstellt dass diejenigen die
noch vorsichtig sind oder unsicher oder
vielleicht auch gar nicht wissen wie das
so genau geht immer noch auch bei den
älteren gleichgesetzt werden mit diesen
radikalen kleinen impfgegner die mit
verschwörungs mythen und wissenschaft
feindlichkeit sehr laut so guter punkt
die leute die sich nicht impfen lassen
ist ja keine homogene sich an genau und
halte deswegen meinte ich entschuldigung
dann gibt es noch die die sich ja auch
nicht impfen lassen können weil sie eine
immunerkrankung haben weiß und hierzu ja
oder weil sie einen so geringen schutz
durch die impfungen haben dass sie
trotzdem umgeben sein müssen von
menschen die geimpft sind und deswegen
finde ich diese debatte zu früh und die
vorbereitungs debatte was kommt im
herbst so spät so das ist doch genau das
was ich gesagt habe wenn wir uns um
andere themen können und nicht jetzt
darum dass ich wieder
freiheitseinschränkung und
exklusivrechte mache ja ohne überhaupt
zu überzeugt und ohne überhaupt auf die
menschen zuzugehen
die möglicherweise einfach nur sagen
junge menschen die sagen ich habe keinen
hausarzt
das ist mir auch zu blöd mich im
impfzentrum irgendwie anzumelden weil
ich weiss gar nicht der termin
vielleicht schreibe ich eine klausur
vielleicht bin ich in meiner freundin
unterwegs muss ich da hingehen wo sie wo
sie sind also auf den campus oder in die
schulen oder ich guck mal ins ausland in
wien werden werden für junge leute
veranstaltung gemacht da kann bekannter
djs auflegen
ja man muss dahin gehen wo mit ja oder
nein stopp werden sie dann gehe ich muss
doch die die die 20 29 anders ansprechen
als die 60 jährigen
also ich hab nicht dass uns dann
missverstehen frauchen bleibt liegen
dass ich habe hohe sympathie für ihre
position aber es ist schwierig was wir
da gerade des kunst ein großes dilemma
pedro leben wollte gerade also es ist
interessant momentan wird ein
altersgruppe gar nicht erwähnt die 112
jährigen also das ist eine gruppe dies
völlig außen vor und die frage ist wir
leben was gerade so wurde familie unser
tochter carina da taucht die frage auf
was macht man eigentlich mit den kleinen
kindern also auch zum thema testen muss
eine familie oder kann eine familie dann
als familie auftreten wenn sie eben
einmal die woche test bezahlt kriegt für
die kinder selbst wenn die eltern sich
impfen lassen oder nicht
bei der elternteile sind zweifach gegen
ob die kinder sind mal liegen zwischen 8
und 12 6 und david und den wollen wir
gemeinsam ins restaurant genau oder in
uhren können die dann könnt ihr nicht
wie genau welche fluggesellschaft nimmt
sie mit all diese themen fliegen nicht
aus ökologischen gründen ist egal es
geht es ist genau um solche fragen diese
fragen sind überhaupt nicht geklärt und
das ist ja dass das geschehen verlagert
sich zunehmend in diese gruppe ist aber
ganz einfach stichwort kindergarten es
dann da ist geht ja auch um solche dinge
und wir laufen exakt wieder in dieselbe
sache war wie letztes jahr und
diskutieren gerade darum ob wir 60 70 80
90 prozent bei den älteren erreichen
das ist ein thema das ist ein thema für
sich gar keine gnade und wir
konzentrieren uns wieder auf diese
gruppe und wir sehen ja aktuell an den
instanzen was läuft bei den kindern ab
und die laufen schutzlos in den nächsten
winter reichen land essent schulden in
kitas ja wie oft was der punkt ist doch
so wichtig das ist ja die gruppe
familien die die größte last getragen
über monate die tragen sie wieder die
[ __ ] wieder und soll wie soll das
geregelt werden
das ist mal ganz praktisch machen der
restaurantbesuch zum beispiel hatte ich
muss kindern dann einen test zur
verfügung stehen damit sie mit ihren
eltern irgendetwas machen politik
behindert werden thema und den daten
mache halt nur das heißt die eltern die
bezahlen ja immer dass sie sagen wie
toll abfahren bezahlen die die preise
damit die leute in der nebensaison
weniger verreisen können da wird ja das
geld gemacht also wir haben selber naja
das sind jetzt unsere enkelkinder selber
durchgemacht als eltern bezahlt man
immer den höchsten preis
es ist wieder so dass das die eltern
dann wenn ich mit den kindern das
unternehmen müssen die haben schon den
ganzen rudel und die die kleinen kinder
finden das nicht lustig wenn sie
getestet werden
und müssten dann selber bezahlen also
ich sag mal die die sich nicht impfen
lassen können
die müssen uns natürlich nicht selbst
bezahlen wenn wir keinen impfstoff für
unter 12-jährige haben es ist muss das
natürlich das ist ganz klar das gesagt
und damit davon ausgegangen er logisch
das trifft nur die ältere gruppe das
kommt aber nicht überall so die kinder
die die ganze last getragen haben
die werden in der debatte fast
vollständig ausgeklammert also damit
auch an der sprache ist schon ganz
kleine anrufe nach frischem blut muss
wenn jetzt allen angewandt gemacht ich
denke alle schüler ist wer es da
eigentlich gemeint na ja wie gesagt es
gibt ja keinen und auf diesen antrag
zwölfjährigen der tat und auch für die
jugendlichen gibt es ja nur sehr
begrenzt
die go empfiehlt das soll endlich mal
ganz genau weiß wer ist alle das sind
eben offensichtlich keine menschen die
in diese gemeinschaft gehören oder die
daraus fallen das ist das was eltern
empört was aber auch etwas ältere kinder
natürlich mit kriegen die ja auch
zwischendurch mal den gesprächen der
eltern lauschen was bedeutet es
eigentlich mein sohn ist 13
was ist eigentlich ein signal an eine
gesellschaft gelangt auch über dich hab
noch gar nicht nachgedacht sie sagen
zwar halle würde ich mal bilder seien
sicher warum du dich kümmern kannst ist
dass du trotzdem möglichst alle
klausuren nachschreiben obwohl digitale
schule hatte
so nehmen kinder und jugendliche das war
und ich spreche ja meinem beruf auch
viel mit etwas älteren jugendlichen 14
bis 16 jährigen und die registrieren
sehr wohl
zusätzlich zu dieser gemeinschaft
doppelt nicht gehören zum einen macht
das mühe
der digitale unterricht die zukunft der
schulen es scheint auch kein
gewinnerthema zusagen genau wie sie das
sagen und zum anderen merken sie dass
sie wenn über das so impfangebot geredet
wird auch über das was sich dann die
menschen in der sogenannten geimpften
freiheit alles leisten können an
kulturellen veranstaltungen überhaupt
nicht dabei sind nicht in den
musikschulen nicht in den kinder
orchester nicht im sportverein
und dieses signal an die nächste
generation finde ich schon verlieren
deswegen müssen wir dafür sorgen dass
zum herbst eben unterricht stattfindet
dass musik unterricht stattfindet und
das nochmal klarzustellen wer sich nicht
impfen lassen kann der bekommt natürlich
auch die tests bezahlt das ist doch
völlig klar
also und wir haben die wir haben diese
leute tests für die kleinen ja die
möglicherweise auch das nicht so mit der
mit mechanismus ist was armin laschet
der viel gescholtenen erwähnt habe ich
gut gemacht hat finde ich auch das ist
wunderbar das sind diese tests die sind
ja sagt die wissenschaft bringt sehr
viel und das müssen wir natürlich
flächendeckend ausrollen und natürlich
auch die luftfilter was ganz wichtig ist
mir gleichgültig haben kein einziger für
unter 12-jährige also müssen wir das
anders regeln aber lass uns noch mal
zurück zum punkt herrscht sie hören auch
schon die ganze zeit aufmerksam zu noch
jemand der sich natürlich auch generell
mit dem thema auf vielen ebenen
beschäftigt sollten geimpft
mehr dürfen als nicht kämpfte das ist ja
die frage um die es im kern geht wie
sehen sie das
was so lange wir noch nicht ganz klar
wissen ob geimpfte anders personen
infizieren als nicht geimpfte ist diese
frage unheimlich schwer zu entscheiden
wir müssen einfach auch da forschung
betreiben wir müssen uns angucken wie
hoch ist denn das ansteckungsrisiko
eines geimpften im vergleich zu einem
nicht geimpften ich glaube da müssen wir
noch zu wenig und insbesondere bei den
kindern das sagen wir immer wieder wir
müssen uns auch mal angucken ab wann
kann denn ein kind zu einem superstar
überhaupt werden das sind auch fragen
wie wissen wir noch gar nicht das team
geht es eher um den medizinischen laien
japanischen aspekt aber auch die
gesellschaftliche debatte
also ich verstehe den punkt schon wenn
wir wir haben doch in ihnen auch in
dieser sendung ich weiß nicht wie oft
der satz gefallen ist es darf keine
impfpflicht geben erster punkt und es
ist völlig in ordnung die leute für sich
die entscheidung treffen sich nicht
impfen zu lassen plötzlich haben eine
veränderte debatte plötzlich merkst du
es war interessant helge braun der der
chef der staatskanzlei bin mir sicher
der vorstoß am wochenende der kann nicht
unabgestimmt vermutlich mal ich also ich
glaube unterstelle nichts wenn ich sage
dass frau merkel möglicherweise davon
bescheid wusste davon aus ja so das war
ein testballon klassischer testballon
mal gucken was passiert und dann kommt
einer nach dem anderen und plötzlich
hast du genau diese debatte
plötzlich wird sie kommt markus söder
dann sagt armin laschet wiederum auch
interessante sich völlig widersprechen
der position innerhalb der union
er sagt kann nicht sein dass das leute
die nicht geimpft sind andere rechte
haben oder weniger rechte haben als
geimpfte dass das nicht einmal innerhalb
der eigenen partei ist es offensichtlich
möglich die reihen wirklich zu schließen
also dass die gesellschaftliche debatte
die die beginnt jetzt
wie schauen sie auf die es ist eine sehr
schwierige debatte her als als als
bürger würde ich auch sagen man darf
eigentlich personen nicht ausgrenzen die
sich zum beispiel nicht impfen lassen
können es gibt eben geht sich um das
können das was anderes das dann sind das
habe ich alle einmal davor die frage des
wollens ist doch auch eine karte
schreiben
wie stellen sie das fest wie stellen sie
das fest ob jemand nicht will oder ob
jemand medizinische psychologische oder
sonstige gründe haben alle gesagt ich
will nicht habe es keine impfpflicht und
das sagen nur den leuten auch immer
wieder und wenn wir das ernst meinen
dann können wir sagen ja gar nicht
führen die wir jetzt führen
also wir haben ja zwei module wir haben
wie einen sanktionen privilegien verbot
und die anderen meine individuelle
freiheit was mir fehlt ist die
verbindung nämlich die dass
selbstbestimmung individuelle freiheit
und verantwortung eigentlich zusammen
gehören vielleicht sogar eine moralische
pflicht dass ich selbst wenn ich als
individuum entscheide ich will mich
nicht impfen lassen immerhin mit
bedenken muss dass das folgen für andere
hat genauso wie ich davon profitiere das
um mich herum leute geimpft sind ist es
so dass meine entscheidung nicht geimpft
zu werden in jedem falle auch folgen hat
für meine umgebung das fehlt mir also
die frage wie solidarisch muss ich
eigentlich sein
auch in bezug auf meiner eigenen
vorbehalte was die impfung angeht ich
will das nicht klein reden das ist es
gibt aber das individuelle freiheiten
auch mit verantwortung für einen
größeren radius als ich selbst verbunden
da war jetzt zuletzt deswegen muss ich
mich ja testen lassen
wir stellen jetzt wieder völlig gleich
das ist ein bisschen schade ungehindert
aber darum geht's ihnen ja nicht darum
geht es mir her kann ich leider innen
geht es mal ganz klar zu sagen bei ihnen
geht sozusagen die frage sollten negativ
getestet
soviel dürfen genauso ist das gericht
nicht geimpft gegen gehen ich will ja
nicht sagen jeder hat den gleichen
zugang zum restaurant sondern derjenige
der sich nicht impfen lassen will und
das ist eine entscheidung die ich nicht
verstehe
die hat man aber akzeptieren und absolut
und der muss dann halt die einen
negativen test vorlegen sodass ist die
debatte trage ich aber wenn mit den
selber bezahlen muss da kommen jetzt
wieder mehr behandeln wir ihn anders
schrägstrich schlechter als der gegner
sozial schwierige frage es ist eine
schwierige frage aber ich muss es halt
in dem moment abwägen und ich muss sagen
ich habe dann das andere beispiel dass
ich sagen muss die allgemeinheit dafür
bezahlen dass er jeden tag irgendwo
daran teilnehmen möchte ja also das ist
noch die frage ob ich das wirklich als
solidargemeinschaft tragen muss und da
habe ich die einzige freund das ist
nicht die einzige frage die jetzt
momentan ja gerade nicht mussten sich
alle vorher testen lassen so das ist
schon umstände nicht genug aber wenn die
das auch noch selber zahlen müssten die
kosten steigen ja für jede kleine
aktivität ich mag manchmal ist es nur
zwei stunden und kostet nicht viel
die verteuert sich erheblich an dem test
noch bezahlen muss und dann ist das
klettern hause kostet auch richtig erst
weiß auch geld keine frage das heißt
oder restaurantbesuch den ich machen
möchte wenn das wieder kommt also war
ich mich etwas 15 euro essen das
kosmodrom und dann auf einmal 25 und ich
eine vierköpfige familie essen gehen
weil ich mich aus mittelhausen gegen
impfung entschieden habe dann mache ich
das nicht mehr das hat also auch wieder
wirtschaftliche konsequenzen und da muss
man sagen die wirtschaft gerade im
touristischen bereich die kratzer jetzt
sowieso gerade bei uns im aartal dreimal
am existenzminimum an der existenz und
wenn das noch dann noch obendrauf kommen
belastungen
das ist für viele vielleicht noch eine
frage frau war in dem zusammenhang
vielleicht sagt muss man so um
aufzuhören
sie sagten gerade es kann sozusagen eine
frage der solidargemeinschaft also
herdenimmunität jetzt mal wirklich
wörtlich genommen
du hast die die geschützte her um dich
herum und dann bist du als nicht
gamestar quasi in dieser herde sicher
mit 19 ist eine das hat der krems die
letzte woche noch mal klar festgestellt
ist eine frau eine erkrankung des alters
ab 65 wird es gefährlich und ab 75
brandgefährlich verstehen sie nicht
jeden der sagt dass auch ich habe kinder
die sind 14 15 20 25 ich möchte die
nicht impfen lassen weil
selbstverständlich hat auch eine impfung
ein risiko das muss man auch mal so klar
und deutlich sagen und was genau dieses
risiko ist das können wir alle nicht
wissen weil diese impfung sehr neues wir
wissen nicht was die möglichen
langzeitfolgen dieser impfung
möglicherweise sind das heißt da damit
einer impfpflicht ganz interessant helge
braun hat er das wort impfpflicht den
mund genommen niemand nimmt dass er den
mund aber man deutet es ziemlich klar an
ob in free kretschmann hat es glaube ich
sogar ausgesprochen und hat dafür
ordentlich haue bekommen kann dann so
eine impfpflicht durch die hintertür ist
an dem eis können wir die wirklich
anordnung mit blick auf die frage dass
ein 25 jähriger in wahrheit ein
vergleichsweise kleines risiko hat an
dieser krankheit zu versterben oder böse
zu erkranken
ich kann mir kein gesetz vorstellen dass
menschen dazu zwingt in deutschland
geben so werden
ich habe versucht auf einen anderen
aspekt hin zu weisen der in dieser
debatte vorkommt dass leute sagen das
geht den staat gar nichts an wie ich
lebe und es stimmt in gewisser weise
auch nur gibt es eben bereiche und eine
panini gehört dazu wurde es nicht ganz
stimmt dass es den staat oder auch meine
mitmenschen nicht interessieren wie ich
lebe weil ich möglicherweise etwa an ran
stecke oder weil ich unwissentlich oder
auch gerne davon profitiere das andere
geimpfte dafür sorgen dass das virus
nicht mal so stark reguliert diese
dimension vermisse ich einfach nur in
der debatte das heißt aber nicht dass
ich nicht leute verstehen gerade auch
leute die sich sehr intensiv auch mit
diesen neuen impfstoffen
auseinandersetzen die sagen ich habe da
vorbehalte ich will da noch mehr wissen
ich wünsche ihnen technologie so genau
da muss man sehr unterscheiden zwischen
denen die in so apokalyptischen szenen
wir denken oder sogar ein verschwörungs
mythen oder denjenigen die sagen auch
leute die sonst sehr im geneigt sind an
dieser stelle wäre ich zurückhaltend
allerdings stimmt es ja nicht ganz dass
dieses virus dann in den harten
verläufen nur eine krankheit des alters
ist sondern es hat also allen dingen
haben sozialen bei aus da kommen wir
dann wieder auf diese test geschichte ja
also menschen die sich infizieren und
auch schwer erkrankt sind sind oft
diejenigen die aufgrund ihrer
beruflichen und ihrer lebenssituation in
ganz anderer weise den virus ausgesetzt
waren und sind als jetzt zum beispiel
ich in meinem falle oder wir die wir
hier alle münzen und die labors der
spielt bei dieser frage testen bezahlen
auch eine große rolle weil das
gleichzeitig immer auch noch milieus
sind die etwas dampf ab ständiger sind
weil sie etwa auch mit anderen medien
noch konfrontiert sind weil sie auch
unsicher sind gegenüber dem deutschen
gesundheitssystem die gründe sind viele
und deswegen gehört auch das zu dieser
solidargemeinschaft die idee dass man
das im blick behält ja aber ist es nicht
gerade da wichtig denn auf diese
menschen zu uns liegen und diese
zielgruppen orientierte ansprache
unbedingt dortmund dann auch
überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten und genau
das argument dass vielleicht dort wo die
skepsis noch da ist ich sage ihr schützt
damit auch eure familie die vielleicht
ältere teilnehmer hat und er schützt
eure umgebung damit und ich glaube was
was wir immer so durcheinander werfen wo
wir auch gar keine zahlen haben ist eben
wo sind eigentlich die wirklichen
impfgegner wie viel sind das eigentlich
und wo ist der anteil der einfach gesagt
hat auch ich weiß irgendwie laisser
faire und ich habe mich noch nicht so
richtig entschieden und ich finde da
müssen wir uns doch jetzt auf die
erstmal zu gehen und sagen wir versuchen
zu überzeugen wir versuchen euch
gelegenheit diese menschen die kammer
nicht überzeugen nein aber erstmal die
nehmen die ich leicht überzeugen kann
und dem ich angebote vor ort machen kann
da müssen wir doch als man das muss erst
mal wirken und sie haben ja genau das
richtige gesagt wir haben der jugend
immer gesagt geht derzeit noch nicht
dran ihr seid noch nicht dran
und jetzt heißt es auf aber jetzt müsst
ihr euch aber ganz schnell impfen lassen
ja da müssen wir doch erst mal sehen
dass das auch läuft und dass wir da
diese angebote macht
und wer es auch erstmal abwarten werfen
nochmal interessanten gedanken in die
runde von christiane woopen die die sie
alle kennen medizinethikerin zwei teile
erster teil keiner hat die pflicht
überhaupt kein risiko für andere
menschen zu sein hat sie recht hat sie
recht müssen wir als gesellschaft bereit
sein ein bestimmtes risiko zu tragen
wie sehen sie das ähnlich wie wir letzte
woche hier darüber diskutiert als es um
die frage ging kinder
ich glaube es gab fünf kinder die an
cupid 19 verstorben sind in deutschland
alle kinder mit vorerkrankungen
das gaben im vergangenen jahr aber
gleichzeitig 20 tote kinder oder 50
sogar aufgrund von influenza und es gab
70 tote kinder bei unfällen im
straßenverkehr alles furchtbar alles
sehr sehr traurig darf man das
miteinander vergleichen müssen wir
irgendwann mal sagen was auf ein
bestimmtes risiko müssen wir irgendwann
auch bereit sein zu gehen
er ist nicht verständlich ich meine
sonst dürfen wir kein auto mehr fahren
also wirklich meinten andere das was sie
gerade sagen wir gefährden andere indem
wir uns nicht impfen lassen nicht
gefährte andere aber wenn ich mich in
ein auto setzen autofahrer also und das
gefährt ich ja auch andere als wir
müssen natürlich müssen wir und da
angeblich er vollkommen recht ja alles
natürlich müssen wir gewisse risiken
tolerieren das geht ja gar nicht dass
keine hat die pflicht überhaupt kein
risiko für andere menschen zu sein frau
war nicht nur keine pflicht sondern es
ist schlicht unmöglich muss man sagen
für andere menschen kein risiko sein es
gibt viele viele lebensbereiche jenseits
ist immer herbeigezogenen autofahrens wo
ich für anderen risiko werde weil ich
unaufmerksam bin weil ich an andere
dinge denken weil ich einfach zu schnell
oder zu langsam fahre oder rede oder
andere dinge tue das ist überhaupt keine
frage und deswegen geht es mir auch
nicht darum eine risikoaverse
gesellschaft werden dass wir uns eine
entsetzliche gesellschaft weil man ja
auch ganz andere dinge nicht mag man
würde sich niemals verlieben zum
beispiel ist alles viel zu riskant wenn
ich auch nicht aber was ich meine
durch und auch nicht immer alle
wichtigen gegeneinander aufzurechnen und
das individuelle risiko was ich trage
wenn ich ohne helm fahrradfahrer ist ein
anderes als wenn ich positiv getestet
auf eine party gehen